hey this is presh talwalkar
find a value of x such that the
following is true
we have the product of several terms
equal to 4 to the power of x minus 3 to
the power of x
the terms are the following we have the
quantity 3 plus 4
times the quantity 3 squared plus 4
squared times the quantity 3 to the
power 4 plus 4 to the power 4 times the
quantity 3 to the power of 8 plus 4 to
the power of 8 times the quantity 3 to
the power of 16 plus 4 to the power of
16 times the quantity 3 to the power of
32 plus 4 to the power of 32.
i want to thank ben craft for sending me
the problem and its solution
and i also want to thank nar235 and
jonathan love for pointing out a mistake
in an earlier version of this video
that wording asked to solve 4 to the
power of x minus 3 to the power of y
but that version of the problem has
infinitely many solutions
so can you find a value of x that works
for this equation
give it a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution
so we just need to find one value of x
that works
the key to this problem is the
difference of squares formula the
quantity a minus b times the quantity a
plus b is equal to a squared minus b
squared
so the first thing we'll do is we'll
reverse the order of addition in each
binomial
now
we will multiply both sides by the
quantity 4 minus 3 which is equal to 1.
on the right hand side we'll simplify
this 4 minus 3 and make it equal to 1.
so the right hand side we still have 4
to the power of x minus 3 to the power
of x
but on the left hand side this quantity
4 minus 3 serves another purpose
if you look at the first two terms the
quantity 4 minus 3
times the quantity 4 plus 3
notice this product is a difference of
squares
so this simplifies to be 4 squared minus
3 squared
and now we have a domino effect on the
rest of the terms
look at the first two terms in this
product
we have the quantity 4 squared minus 3
squared times the quantity 4 squared
plus 3 squared
this is another difference of squares
so we get 4 to the power of 4 minus 3 to
the power 4.
and now if you look at the next term
we have another difference of squares
we'll end up simplifying to be 4 to the
power of 8 minus 3 to the power of 8
and we do this one more time
the first two terms again will simplify
to be the difference of squares
so we have 4 to the power of 16 minus 3
to the power of 16 and we do it once
more
so we have 4 to the power of 32 minus 3
to the power of 32 and we're going to do
it one last time
so we end up with 4 to the power of 64
minus 3 to the power of 64.
and we're done we found a value x is
equal to 64
that works for this equation
did you see the trick
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com and you can catch
me on social media either at mind your
decisions or at preshtalwalkar